- So there's a bunch
of reasons why a website
might want to track you.
And depending on your opinion,
you might think some
of these are reasonable
and you might think some
of them are unreasonable.
Just to understand,
imagine if you were to
go to say Khan Academy
and you were to do some work,
well it might be nice that if you were
to come back another day that,
that work isn't lost.
And so that might be a reason
why you would want Khan
Academy to know who you are.
Now, there's a bunch
of different ways that this could happen.
The most obvious way is
by having an account with
a username and a password.
So when you type in your
username and password
the site knows exactly who you are.
It can retrieve your data from a database
and then you can pick up
right where you left off.
That's probably the
most obvious to people.
And it's also the most
obvious how to not be tracked
in that way is that you log out.
But just because you logged out or just
because you don't have a username
and password doesn't mean
that you can't be tracked by a site.
There's several other
ways that can be tracked
that you should know about
and also know how to
undo them if possible.
Another way is leveraging
something called cookies.
Cookies, even if you don't
have an account on a site,
most web browsers are
going to allow the website
to place a little bit of
text on your computer.
So the browser, which is running
on your computer is gonna place it,
so that next time your browser goes
to that site again, the site will say,
oh this is the same person
whose cookie I put there.
And then there might that
cookie might have a little bit
of data associated with it and say, okay
there could be some useful things.
We can pick up where we left off.
We can customize for what
you were looking for.
Or you might say that's
a little bit creepy,
that a site that I
didn't get permission to
is able to keep track of me.
And so you might want
to delete your cookies
which your browser will allow you to do.
Now cookies, as I saId,
they have their benefits.
This one of the reasons
why you can often stay logged
into a website because the website says,
oh, this is a cookie.
This is the person who keeps logging in.
You might want the personalization
of the advertisements
or any other customizations
without logging in.
And that's where a cookie could be useful.
But if you don't want it, of
course, you can delete it.
Now, another way that a
website can keep track
is your IP address.
When your web browser
which is running on your
computer or on your phone
wants to look at a website,
it sends a request to that website,
and then that request sends the data,
sends the website back.
And so in order to send the data back
it needs an address for your
phone or for your computer
and that's going to be in
the form of an IP address.
Now you can imagine if that
site knows your IP address
and then if you were to
come from the same device
with the same IP address,
again, it'll say, okay,
it's at least the same device.
Maybe it's the same person.
And then they might be able
to track you in that way.
Once again, it might be
for some good uses, like customization
or maybe it's things that you
aren't so comfortable with.
Now, what gets extra interesting
and might be useful or not useful,
depending on your point
of view is that it's not
necessarily just your
relationship with one website.
For example, you might have an
advertiser that puts cookies
on a bunch of websites,
and so can keep track
of you as you go from site to site.
And so then it's getting, at least for me,
I don't like the fact that people can see
how I'm moving around on the internet.
Or I remember recently I was looking
for a mountain bike and I
did it on one eCommerce site.
And then all of a sudden it seemed
like the whole internet knew
that I wanted to buy a mountain bike.
I didn't end up buying a mountain bike.
Now some of you might say, that's nice.
You know, the internet knows
I want a mountain bike.
I'd like to keep being presented
with ads on mountain bikes.
Some of you might say,
hey, that's not so cool.
It was just, well, you
know, a random search I did.
And it's kind of weird
that the internet is starting
to build this profile of me
of someone who might be in
the market for mountain bikes.
And so once again, deleting
your cookies can go a long way
to preventing that type of thing,
if you're uncomfortable with it.
And then IP addresses, that's
a little bit harder to hide.
Sometimes you have dynamic IP addresses
sometimes it changes, but the clearest way
of protecting your IP address is
if you use something like
a virtual private network
which does get a little bit more complex.
Now related to all of this,
some of you also might be thinking
about being tracked when you do a search.
You might see that,
hey, these suggested searches
that the site is giving,
it seems like it's kind of specific to me.
And that's because in many cases it is.
The search engine probably
has placed cookies, or it's
keeping with an IP address
of things that you have
searched for before.
And the things that you have clicked on.
And so it could use that maybe
to give you different search results,
maybe to change what the auto-complete is.
It also might be keeping
track of a search history.
So the search history could be useful,
if you wanna look
at other sites that
you have been to before
or you might not want that around.
You might not want the
site or someone else
who if you just happen
to be using your computer
to see what you've been searching for.
So most browsers, sorry
most search engines are
going to let you delete that.
So there's a lot more to it.
This is just kind of
the tip of the iceberg,
but think about how you
may or may not be tracked
and think about how you may
or may not want to be tracked.
And good hygiene is,
especially if you're at a public
computer log out of things.
That's also so other people
can't use use your account,
really be thoughtful about
whether you even want to
create an account for a site.
Is this something that you really need?
What are going to be the benefits for you?
Think about whether you
want to accept cookies?
I would recommend deleting
cookies pretty regularly.
It might have some negatives.
You might have to re-log into a few sites,
but there's probably a
lot of other shady sites
that no longer can
track what you're doing.
But even if you do all of those things
still be very careful
and very conscientious.